uh The Last of Us show is pretty good oh
did you watch that yeah it really is
yeah I haven't played the games but the
show's [__] good okay it's very good
you should watch it I mean the game's
okay here's here's the thing about The
Last of Us tell me the thing about the
last time they would have to [__] up
really hard to make The Last of Us show
bad because I feel like The Last of Us
game is already a HBO show with gameplay
it's true but I I think that there is
still that you do still have to kind of
translate certain things to a screen
that are a bit hard to do oh for sure
yeah and I think also
obviously you know you've got to get
these you've got to make people fall in
love with these main characters again
yeah
um and all you need to do is just take
the writing from the game it's well yeah
there are some some sentences that are
straight from the game yeah
um but yeah I mean Pedro Pascal is like
amazing okay yeah it's so [__] good
yeah everything I've seen him in he's
just been the goat and also he's like
he's a really good meme the one where
he's crying and laughing oh yeah there's
someone from that's from a like a zoom
acting class that he's doing and the
director's like Okay show them somebody
who's uh happy but then like it was like
some kind of motivation where something
good uh bad happens and they don't know
how to deal with it right it just
literally just goes
it's really either full club's even
weirder all right it's pretty fun though
but it's so good please watch it it's
something like one episode out right now
one episode out of the time of recording
dating your episode uh but yeah no even
the one episode was it was so funny I I
I would bet a lot of money that it's
gonna keep being great because I they
would really have to do something dumb
to [__] this up yeah so far it's a
pretty simple story I haven't yeah I
haven't uh simple uh Simple Story
complex characters you know
um and it's usually the best yeah yeah
yeah and I think it could be Avatar but
um it's just so nice but HBO does
something they're so [__] good at
making TV shows yeah yeah except for
Velma that was bad we don't talk about
that though
action I watched one episode I'm out
yeah I just watched a bunch of Clips on
Twitter and uh oh my God okay here's the
question do you think they made that
show as yes rage bait show yes
they could have made a good show they
didn't want to it's HBO they can make a
[__] good show if they want to make
it they're like if you want a TV series
done the best HBO had like the dudes I
don't know who they have on speed dial
but they just don't miss everything HBO
if you look at some of the best TV shows
in history half of them HBO I feel I
feel like just because they must have
some kind of like they have must have
some kind of like big vetting process
about what shows yeah I think they also
have like a roster of like just really
great writers directors everything like
they they just they've been doing it so
long and I think they just they're just
great I don't know I again I just
shouldn't be speculating but I mean the
history has been around for a very long
time and they've they clearly have you
know some of the most impactful shows on
like pop culture they've had
um so vulma is not going to be one of us
it's had an impact it has had an impact
because
right like uh House of dragon
um what else is HBO Band of Brothers
this is HBO yeah because I've always
felt like they've had a very their
approach to TV shows has always been
very cultivated you know it's it's
something that they don't approve every
show I'm like like Netflix yeah every
show that they do approve is always of
like the highest quality yeah I kind of
feel similar to like going to like the
manga world like Shonen Jump I don't
know I don't know what the Shonen Jump
secret sources you know but somehow
every generation they are able to make
the biggest and most impactful anime
shows I mean I mean their generation
yeah I'm sure with talented authors but
I'm also I I you know there's probably
the dudes who are curating turn and jump
yeah probably you know if I'm a new uh
mangako or anything right and you've got
these dudes who've been working at 40
years who can give you any insight and
can steer you in the right direction
like that's that's probably worth a lot
I mean they say it's harder to get a
serialization or Shonen Jump than it is
to be accepted into Tokyo University I
believe it or just like insane if you if
you ask a Japanese person that all right
like it's literally one in a million
like yeah I can't imagine the amount of
like you know mediocre to [__] manga
that they have to sift through to be
like yeah all right uh we don't know how
to tell you this but uh
go home yeah because it's like it's like
way easier to fall off than to keep
putting out [__] bangers all the time
that's why odor the goat plays the goat
like I remember when uh Naruto and
bleach ended there was this like huge
[__] hole and everyone's like oh the
big three died his anime is Shonen going
to be as popular as it can be and for
like for like a few like for like a good
like three four years nothing came to
like take that spot and I remember
thinking oh maybe maybe this is time
flood other types of shows because
that's when Attack on Titan and one
punch man got really popular yeah and
I'm like okay maybe maybe Sharon jump is
slowly like falling off who knows maybe
they can't make something as impactful
as Naruto and bleach and then turns out
I they just needed like a [__] buffer
uh because then my hero Academia came
out Demon Slayer chainsaw man Jiu Jitsu
kaisen spy family [__] it just like now
they've gone from like the big three to
like the big seven or eight or some [__]
like that it's got a strong roster yeah
everything's good yeah I'm like what is
the secret so tell me the secrets God
heroin black Tire heroin God please
bring it to the [__] Easter guys we
[__] need that although there is
still that like you know very real scare
that I think all like Shannon fans are
wondering especially with Shonen Jump of
like all right you know a lot of these
like good shows that you you mentioned
right like the you know they're carrying
but everyone knows that behind the
scenes one piece is still carrying
Shonen Jump pretty [__] hard like
oda's shoulders must be cracked because
of just how much he's carrying Shonen
jump right now so everyone I think in
the back of their minds is like all
right what's gonna happen
like what's gonna happen to Sean and
John win one piece I know we don't need
to worry about that we don't need to
worry yeah so they're just like I bet
like shoe Asia just like begging odor to
be like please don't stop I beg of you
oh they'll make Luffy the emperor
I'm scared because I don't think one
piece is going to die I think it's going
to be a boruto kind of situation I mean
are we gonna get a two-piece yeah
because you started reading one piece
you're not like completely up to date
but you can already tell that the world
of one piece is so [__] vast that I
already know they're gonna try to
they're gonna try to spin-offs not like
I wouldn't say milk it but it has
potential for so many interesting
stories within the world like a ton of
prequels already from what I've seen
that I'd be like I'd like to know what
happened before I mean they're already
doing that like they released like a an
ace story prequel in the long end that's
like popped off recently yeah so it's
like yeah they're already doing it but
like the moment one piece actually ends
they're like all right we're gonna list
out all these characters that didn't get
enough backstory just make individual
Manga and Anime though Otis seems like
the kind of dude who's not gonna stop
writing manga until he physically cannot
like yeah you see it like just saying
one piece you're like this dude's not
gonna stop no like this is not the type
of dude who says I think I'm done
he is the type of dude who will be like
I'm just gonna not stop doing this until
I physically am unable to oh yeah yeah
for sure yeah I just I just hope okay
here's here's my hope because I know Ori
discovers like a clever porn he likes or
something or he discovers Idol muscles
you know there's the two there's there's
a couple of ways you can have downfalls
yeah oh no let me introduce you to the
world of genjun impact oh my God could
you imagine it's like ah this week uh
one piece is on Hiatus because
[Laughter]
oh
it's like the one thing I wish for when
one piece ends is that they give us
some time a few years to mourn because I
feel like you know you know what I mean
yeah because like you know when when
something's not Clarity right when
something ends sometimes you just need a
little time to just let that ending sink
in and just know okay that that's it uh
because I felt like with Naruto I
remember reading that last chapter and I
was just like [__] man a part of my
childhood has died
um and then narrated the last movie got
announced like immediately afterwards I
was like
Jesus Christ Matt come on give me some
time here man come on I'm just it's like
it's like a family member dying and then
you're not being like here's your brand
new cousin it's like come on man I just
attended your funeral man come on I'm
mourning you right now come on Daddy
chill please come on oh my God like like
I I know they're not I'm not gonna let
one piece die straight away but I hope
at least they'll let the Legacy
sink in for a little bit before they
start [__] milking the [__] out yeah
yeah I hope so that's that's that's my
hope at least yeah who knows